oh I'm so excited about this this is the
new DJI mic 2 now I had started using
the DJI mic one a little bit late like I
didn't use it when it first came out the
first time that I had used the mic one I
was like why have I not been using this
since it first came out well an update
to the mic one we now have the mic 2
this has an 18h hour battery it has 14h
hour internal recording and it has 32bit
float internal recording which is
incredible for getting varying typ of
volume I tend to be a little bit
animated sometimes when I'm filming so I
can go from Hi how are you to all the
way over the top this also has a 250 M
range which is 820 ft and we also have
this little lavalier
mic I love the little carrying bag
here's the case ooh this looks nice it's
like a more metallic finish the previous
one was a little plasticky like this
feels like industrial like a much better
feel already feels like a premium
upgrade so we got a sneak peek of the
mic 2 with the new osmo mobile 3 it came
with one of the little microphones so
ever since I saw that sneak peek I could
not wait until the full thing came out
something else that I like you'll see
this says press to unlock the other one
before just opened up so I feel like
they probably did that because sometimes
it would come open or if you dropped it
everything would kind of go everywhere
so this is a nice little added feature
here they are oh man it just feels so
premium like everything just feels so
much better like this is such an upgrade
already so here's the microphones you'll
see that they are also translucent like
super pretty like such a nice
aesthetic can't wait to try these out I
also like that they colorcoded the out
and the in this little dial wheel is
also a nice little addition so this will
allow you to select things on the screen
so I'm going to set this up in English
please so already I'm obsessed with this
and this is definitely something that I
will not leave home without this will
definitely be in my two travel kits now
the thing that I also like about this is
it'll allow you to hook it up to your
phone so this has access right here
where you will plug in either your
lightning or USBC and since we are now
USB iPhone I'm hoping this works with
the
case it does the other one didn't work
with the case going to put one of these
back
in okay oh my gosh hello test test test
okay this is great I'm so excited all
right we're going to do our first test
test test test okay here it is I'm
officially a vertical content creator
now you can um see because I have got my
tiny microphone and I'm holding it up in
front of my face which actually is
brings up another point so if I do want
to put this on my shirt I could just go
like that look at me I've got my magnet
it also has a clip now why I also love
these is I also love using these as a
backup microphone I can use my
traditional setup that I have my lav mic
but I can also have this as a backup and
constantly be recording so if something
fails on my main setup I can have this
backup always running like I mentioned
in the intro if I did get a little bit
louder my audio won't Peak because of
that 32-bit and that's pretty incredible
especially for people who tend to get a
little excited and blow out all of their
audio I've been there well I cannot wait
to continue to test this out and I look
forward to seeing what you guys think I
think this is a pretty big upgrade and I
could not be more excited to be
reviewing this oh I love this lock man
everything about it is so perfect so
[Music]
far
here it is okay I'm now testing this out
in my setup and I'm using this instead
of my normal microphones that I usually
use and these were something that saved
my CES because while I was at the
convention using the traditional
Sennheiser microphones that I use
there's so much interference because
everyone in the entire building is
basically using these different
frequencies so that tends to affect any
type of Wireless microphones now why
this was key is you're able to record
directly to this so there's no
interference this actually will act like
a tiny little disc drive so it'll record
you plug it into your computer and the
audio files will automatically pop up
it's also so small and portable and
compact I mean look at the difference
between what I was using and now I'm
using the new DJI Mike 2os so now I want
to plug in the little lav attachment so
you can see what it sounds like which I
feel like this a lot of times would be
something that I would be normally using
unless I want to be super trendy and you
know hold the tiny microphone for the
whole video which yeah okay I get it but
also you don't have to do that that's
what these are for now what I love about
this little Laval ler microphone is it
actually has a little rotating clip so
depending upon which side you put it on
so if you have a jacket you may want to
put it on the left or the right or if
you want to put it in the center you can
just rotate the little clip and it'll
give you the perfect direction for the
microphone the other thing that I love
is how easily this integrates into a
phone scenario so if you do a ton of
recording on your phones this is so
gamechanging all you have to do is plug
it into your phone the iPhone
automatically recognizes it if you like
you can also use direct Bluetooth
connection to your phone I like having
the transmitter plugged in so I can see
my levels and kind of monitor what's
happening this even has built-in AI
noise cancelling so this will help with
your vocal recording so I've definitely
noticed an improved audio quality over
the previous version I also really like
the interface on the receiver itself
they definitely change this up and it's
so much more intuitive and you can see
right here that I'm actually recording
because there is a little red box around
it this will let you know if one of the
mic packs is recording on it internally
so this is always good to know and I
love the way that these integrate with
the DJI osmo pocket 3 you may have seen
this microphone make its first little
cameo in that unboxing but now that
they're officially out you can purchase
the entire kit this is something that I
recommend if you are a beginner or an
advanced videographer this is something
that you need in your kit this is not
sponsored this is genuinely me speaking
I will not leave home without this this
goes in my purse this goes in my
backpack if I'm leaving the house these
are with me because I never know if I
might need to record something on my
phone the convenience factor like I
could Rave about these all day long now
I feel like I didn't really do an
extensive review here in this video but
the amount that I have tested these and
use them even using the previous
versions I cannot say enough good things
about it I hate to keep saying
gamechanging but for creators these are
it they're incredible let me know if you
guys have any questions feel free to
leave them in the comments and thank you
to DG for sending me these two checkouts
again this isn't a sponsored review this
is just my honest opinion they are so
perfect and I love them so much if you
want to get more information there will
also be a link in the description and I
look forward to having this be our new
audio setup and I know Tyler who helps
me film is also going to be very excited
because it's so small and compact it's
going to make our filming days so much
easier when we're out and about and also
for me too because like look at this
this is so small it's great I don't have
this huge pack to carry around h i just
I'm so happy